we have a voicemail number it's 2192
david p we haven't heard much from eric
from massachusetts lately he's this
coveted conspiracy theorist who's been
calling off calling in off and on for
the last two to three years he's back
and he's accusing me of things that i
never said hey david it's sarah from
mass um i get the
idea that you are frosting at the mouth
to have lockdowns and masks again when
did i say that and have everybody be
the economy be crippled while you sit in
your uh ivory tower no i want the
economy to do well so my stocks and
bonds go up and dictate what everyone
should do wrong um
you know like i told you i was a leftist
democrat had no problem with
progressivism but why do you think i
found you
but uh when clover hit i knew they were
lying that's right this guy was a
progressive then all of a sudden there's
a virus and he becomes an unhinged
right-wing conspiracy theorist sounds
more like it's a mind virus that
infected them gonna do with politics
it's about lies and truths
you know what i mean and like you said
oh they're not gonna start something for
the midterms and then they said it what
will your excuse be now the midterms are
coming lockdowns are coming get the [ __ ]
out of here all right so anyway i don't
support any of that stuff i've said
nothing about it eric is very very
delusional and sometimes i think he's
reacting to things other hosts have said
like i think sometimes it's just he's
confused
we are going to talk on the bonus show
today about the lawsuit against the pga
for suspending golfers who played in the
saudi-funded golf tour we will talk
about josh hawley's vote against finland
and sweden joining nato and we will talk
about georgia residents being able to
claim embryos as dependents on state
taxes listen if nothing else they're
being consistent if that's a person
you should be able to claim an embryo as
a dependent i mean it's at least
consistent
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
well alex i don't know that you're in a
position to really say much about the
bonus show right now you can sign up at
joinpackman.com we will see you then